Traductor: Astrid Chavoya
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Desde la Antigua Grecia hasta el siglo XX,
Aristóteles, Sigmund Freud
y muchos otros estudiosos
buscaban lo mismo:
testículos de anguila.
La anguila europea o anguilla anguilla,
podía encontrarse en los ríos de Europa,
pero nadie la había visto aparearse.
Y pese a numerosas disecciones,
nadie pudo encontrar huevos de anguila
o identificar sus órganos reproductivos.
Sin información, los naturalistas
propusieron varias teorías.
Aristóteles propuso que
emergían espontáneamente del lodo.
Plinio el Viejo argumentó que
se frotaban contra las rocas
y los residuos resultantes cobraban vida.
Otros decían que nacían en los techos,
surgían de las branquias de otros peces,
o incluso que surgían de los escarabajos.
Pero la verdadera historia de
su reproducción es aún más complicada.
Y para resolver este misterio
los estudiosos tendrían que reformularse
siglos de investigaciones.
Actualmente, sabemos que
su ciclo de vida consta de cinco etapas:
larvas leptocéfalas, angulas, angulones,
anguilas amarillas y anguilas plateadas.
Dadas las grandes diferencias físicas
entre estas fases,
no sería extraño pensar
que son animales diferentes.
De hecho, eso es lo que
los naturalistas europeos pensaban.
Los investigadores sabían de
las leptocéfalas y las angulas,
pero no pensaron que se relacionaban
con los angulones y las anguilas amarillas
que vivían a cientos de kilómetros.
Además, las anguilas no desarrollan
órganos reproductivos hasta más adelante.
Y el tiempo que pasan
en los ríos de Europa
lo pasan como angulones.
Entonces, ¿cuándo se reproducen?,
¿y dónde lo hacen?
La vida de la anguila europea empieza
en las aguas salinas
del Triángulo de las Bermudas.
En el pico de la temporada anual
de ciclones,
miles de larvas de anguila
salen del mar de los Sargazos.
De ahí, siguen trayectorias
de migración a Norte América y Europa—
continentes que estaban más cerca
cuando las anguilas establecieron
estas rutas hace 40 millones de años.
Durante los próximos 300 días,
las larvas siguen las corrientes marinas
por 6500 km a la costa de Europa—
convirtiéndola en una de
las migraciones marinas más largas.
Al llegar, habrán crecido
aproximadamente 45 mm
y se habrán transformado
en angulas semitransparentes.
Y no sólo cambia su apariencia.
Si la mayoría de los peces marinos
entraran a las aguas salobres de la costa
sus células se llenarían de agua dulce
y explotarían.
Pero cuando las anguilas
llegan a la costa,
sus riñones cambian para retener más sal
y mantener la salinidad de su sangre.
Un sinfín de estos nuevos peces
migra a arroyos y ríos,
apilándose para deshacerse
de obstáculos y depredadores.
Aquellos que logran llegar al otro lado,
se convierten en angulones.
Al haber llegado a sus sitios de caza,
los angulones empiezan a comer
tanto como puedan.
Estos omnívoros crecen
en proporción a sus dietas
y durante la siguiente década
se convierten en anguilas amarillas.
En esa etapa,
crecen hasta medir unos 80 cm
y por fin desarrollan órganos sexuales.
Pero la última fase de su vida—
y el secreto de su reproducción—
sigue siendo un misterio.
En 1896, los investigadores identificaron
a las leptocéfalas como larvas de anguila
y dedujeron que habían llegado a Europa
desde el Océano Atlántico.
Pero para encontrar
este misterioso criadero
alguien tiene que hacer
un estudio exhaustivo del océano
para encontrar larvas de no más de 30mm.
Y es aquí donde entra Johannes Schmidt.
Durante los siguientes 18 años,
este oceanógrafo danés
rastreó las costas de cuatro continentes,
encontrando leptocéfalas
cada vez más pequeñas.
Finalmente, en 1921, encontró
la más pequeña hasta entonces,
en el borde sur del mar de los Sargazos.
A pesar de saber sobre su migración,
los científicos aún no las han visto
aparearse en la naturaleza,
ni han encontrado sus huevos.
Las principales teorías
sugieren que se reproducen
en un torbellino de fertilización externa
donde los espermas
fertilizan huevos flotantes.
Pero las fuertes corrientes
y las algas del mar de los Sargazos
han hecho que esta teoría
sea difícil de confirmar.
Los investigadores ni siquiera
saben dónde buscar,
ya que no han podido rastrear una anguila
durante el regreso de su migración.
Hasta enfrentar estos desafíos,
el antiguo misterio de estas anguilas
se nos escapará de las manos.